notre reporter david qualify sur place à
marseille il a rencontré l'adjoint en
charge de la politique du logement
plusieurs objectifs suite à la venue d'
emmanuel macron dans la cité phocéenne
pour ces trois prochains jours avec en
point d'orgue évidemment l'insécurité
depuis les dernières quinze personnes
ont trouvé la mort dans des règlements
de comptes et ce chiffre assez évoquant
seulement dix juges d'instruction pour
toute la région et 10 millions
d'habitants d'où à la demande de plus de
moyens par le maire de la ville benoît
payan autre sujet brûlant qui a fait
parler ces derniers jours c'est la
polémique et un concernant cette
intervention de police 1 dans la cité à
des flamands patrick amico adjoint au
maire en charge du logement et de la
lutte contre l'habitat indigne a répondu
à nos questions concernant à cette
action de police aujourd'hui sur
marseille ce n'est pas que le problème
du logement indigne qui vraiment
centrale dans nos préoccupations c'est
aussi et avant tout la problématique des
écoles c'est aussi et avant tout la
problématique des transports qui font
que certains quartiers sont complètement
enclavé mal desservies et contribuer
totalement avec des problèmes de
sécurité que l'on connaît dans ces
quartiers maintenant quand on voit très
bien aujourd'hui que le traitement de
ces sites et passe par une action
globale passe par une action pas
uniquement centrée sur le problème de la
drogue ou le problème des points de
deane le problème des squats c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons aussi
demandé et je pense que le président ne
manquera pas d'y faire référence au
premier ministre au lendemain même de l'
incendie des flamands la création
d'états généraux de lutte contre
l'habitat indigne à marseille pour que
vraiment on repose de manière
complètement global cette affaire de de
lutte contre l'habitat indigne l
insécurité au centre des débats mais ce
n'est pas tout les transporte également
la rénovation des logements insalubres
sera au centre des discussions plus de
sept ministres accompagneront le chef de
l'état pour ce plan a annoncé comme du
jamais vu par l elysée reste à savoir
dans quel état d'esprit l'exécutif va
aborder cette visite si ce n'est elle
pas seulement un coup de com mais du
concret voilà ce qu'on réclame à tout
prix ici à marseille